[Music]
hey everybody uh it's me Josh and today
we're going to be talking about a couple
of examples of great preparation in this
opening that we call the Berlin defense
in the Royal Lopez variation so the key
here is that absolute Knight of six
black is announcing the desire to reach
an end game that follows the moves
Knight D6 and after it takes a knight F5
this end game has been contested very
sharply at the highest level I think
that probably doesn't require too much
introduction here so I'm not going to go
super involved with the historical
background or anything like this but I'm
doing the long story short this is
probably the most common opening we see
at the highest level of Chess between
super Grand Masters and such and it's
slowly assuming to trickle its way down
towards the 24 to 2500 level so what
we're going to be doing today is we're
going to be taking a look at this
opening which has a great reputation for
solidity for black and is completely
well deserved being an extremely
difficult opening for white to reach an
interesting position against we're going
to be looking at a couple of interesting
tries today
so the first game that we're going to be
looking at is the game uh with as white
we have international Master Edward song
and with black we have the strong FM
gory Shankar so this was played in a
norm tournament in Charlotte in 2021 so
we're going to be looking at Knight F6
and today one of the or maybe the way
for white to play against the Berlin is
going to be starting with D3 a fairly
conservative move but the fact that
white has the potential to play Bishop
take C6 does introduce a level of
dynamism into the position so after
Bishop C5 white has two principal tries
here one is with Bishop takes C6 as
we're going to be focusing on for the
first part of the lecture today and the
other being C3
which intends to build a big Pawn center
with Tempo against the bishop on C5
today we're going to be looking at
Bishop takes C6
uh yeah unfortunately the E5 Pawn is not
hanging here due to a queen D4 Fork but
after Knight bd2 castles Knight C4 white
is intending to use the pressure on E5
to force a concession from black and
indeed in this position the most con
move is 97.
so uh what I want to talk about here are
a couple of ideas so normally white uh
tries to Castle short and then perhaps
goes for some sort of
situation where they intend to prove
that the devil pawns on the C file are
weak usually not terribly successful
black has a very solid position and the
bishop here at the end of the day so the
move that I'm going to be talking about
today and was played in the game per my
suggestion is the move Knight E3
so this move might be a little bit hard
to understand at first so as I mentioned
before most commonly White Castles and
the position is very quiet but several
years ago there became a great interest
for white playing with the move Queen E2
and intending to like Castle long so
after F6 uh rookie 8 and F6 being very
common news for black intending to
reroute that D7 Knight over to D4
through E6 and here white can play G4
and this has been played several times
for example just through a slightly
different move forward we have this game
here where Wei beat Navara and after
some long sequence white ended up
crashing through with an attack on the
king side
so but people don't normally play this
way anymore as in this position people
have found that uh B5 has been able to
give black acceptable counter play after
93 Knight B6 uh position becomes very
what happens to my arrow keys
okay there we go uh Knight V6 is uh and
is a situation where black generally is
considered to have pretty good counter
play
so the idea with the move 93 is that
white is still intending to go for an
attack on the king side the move does
prepare G4 and white may be looking at a
potential Knight F5 and steps out of the
way of B5 simultaneously so after rookie
8 G4 the most common continuation for
black here would be Knight F6 and after
H3 white is now able to freeze the queen
side as white has no particular reason
to Castle along with the center being so
closed and white has good chances to
develop an attack in this position so
this is the central idea of the move 93.
in the game gory decided to play Bishop
B4 check and then A5
so uh essentially black is intending to
trade the Bishops although I'm not
entirely sure why this was decided but
in the case of a very rare move this
move 93 it's very common for people to
lose track of what they want to be doing
as unfamiliar positions can often lead
to Stakes so after H4 white is simply
carrying out the idea and white ended up
reaching an advantage fairly smoothly
for example in this position white is
already able to continue with Rook G1
and the threats of G5 coming in the next
few moves are very serious if black were
to try to contest this with G6 then
after Knight H6 King G7 white simply
proceeds with the attack and results in
a winning position so on move 14 we
already have a more or less a winning
Advantage for White against the most
solid opening in chess so I would call
that a successful instance of
preparation
um in the game after Bishop E3 the
specific moves here are not super
important but essentially after H5 the
king side text very strong white has
ideas of H6 so
black counters this with H6 himself but
the closing of the king side is very
positionally unfavorable so even though
black has relatively unlikely to be
checkmated here given the excellent
control of the G5 Square white is going
to be having a really powerful position
after Knight H4 and then Knight G6 wow
my arrow keys are not uh very happy with
me
um but after Queen F2 Bishop F7 so now
we can see that if white were to Castle
long then B5 and B4 would be problematic
and this is yet another reason why the
initial idea with white playing Queen E2
is not as effective as this one so on
this position white is able to Simply
hide the King on G2 where it is going to
be completely safe and indeed now white
is well equipped to open the center now
that the King has left
so we have Bishop C3 and Rook D1 so
white has a very dominating position
here Queen C8 and white is already able
to play Knight G6 as after H takes G6
it's very unlikely that black is able is
going to be able to take on G6 at any
point so doubled pawns do not really
represent a serious weakness in this
case
and the game Queen F1 was played first
and after Knight G6 we see King H7 so
it's definitely not a problem for white
to end up taking this bishop we end up
with opposite colored Bishops but the
activity of the pieces in the pawn
structure remains very favorable to
White after Queen D7
we see a situation in which black is
going to eventually have to allow an
exchange of Queens but the Rook will
infiltrate through the seventh Rank and
leave black with a serious disadvantage
thank you so night 96 Rook D1 Route 58
black is hoping for an exchange of
Brooks but it's not really possible for
black to initiate
after King G8 and now it is time to
break through with E5 so again after F
takes E5 it should take Z5 this Pawn
structure would be extremely unfortunate
for black given that C7 is a weak and G7
is a weak so this just ties back into
the sort of disadvantage of the Berlin
where the doubled C pawns remember many
end games unfavorable to Black if he
does not possess the bishop pair
so after E5 black decided to try to
complicate the position with Knight D4
which in fact actually does lose pretty
much immediately to a slightly
complicated sequence evolving 97 and
Bishop takes D4 as Rook takes D4 here is
unfortunately dropping upon to Knight C6
and C takes d49 C6 is also winning a
pawn for white and both cases should
result in a fairly simply winning end
game primarily due to the king Side Pawn
structure being very unfavorable for
black in addition to this extra Pawn
unfortunately the game after Rook takes
d8 uh White quickly lost the thread uh
I'm guessing that he missed F takes E5
in some sort of time pressure
um as uh in this position white is still
able to achieve a winning position with
move 97 and Knight G6 as Bishop takes G6
Bishop takes C5 check it's a very
powerful discovered attack
um and after King J at Knight takes E5
white should be able to pick up the D4
Pawn at the end of the day and achieve a
winning position but unfortunately in
time travel white was not able to find
this resource and ended up sacrificing
The Exchange in an unsound way and
losing so very unfortunate to lose but
hopefully I was able to explain the
process through which we reached this
move 93
basically just understanding that we're
trying to achieve an improved version of
a known idea and how specifically this
move was able to
throw off black and present him with an
uncomfortable situation after G4
okay so now we're going to be talking
about a couple of other ideas as well so
this is not the only try of course black
is also able to play differently against
this resource so the game we're going to
be talking about here
um
so the stem game I have here is between
kariakin and topalov in 2019
so after E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight C6
Bishop B5 Knight F6
castles Knight take Z4
rookie196 so rookie one is another move
that is also pretty common these days so
as to avoid the end game is after 96
Knight takes E5 we will usually end up
with a fairly symmetrical Pawn structure
but in this case there is no such
endgame and there is no simplification
of pieces compared to the main line of
D4
9 takes E5 Bishop E7 Bishop F1 so this
is all well-known Theory and indeed
white normally simply Retreats the rook
and from there there are there's a lot
of theory but for the most part black is
going to eventually be able to get in
some sort of Knight F5 or 98 followed by
D5 and the Very symmetrical position
means that black is probably going to be
mostly okay
so in this position uh cardio I believe
the cardio interpolive game is the first
example
um
we're going to be looking a little bit
uh further at some more lines after this
theoretical idea but in this game white
played Bishop D3 so Bishop D3 has the
idea of sacrificing The Rook on E5 as
it's very difficult for black to proceed
logically without eliminating this Rook
unfortunately for black since since the
black pieces don't coordinate too well
at the moment
so after Bishop takes E5 takes E5 98
Knight C3 it looks very odd but uh the
white pieces are positioned very well
and then Knight on E8 is not really is
not placed very well to deal with any
sort of King side attack sort of
dominated by the pawn at E5 in fact so
this is the central idea of this move
Bishop D3
so after uh after Knight C3 the only way
for black to try to free himself would
be with the move D6 just trying to
eliminate this E5 pawn and therefore try
to uh
rescued and I don't eat after Queen H5
G6 and queen H6 we have a situation
where black needs to defend here pretty
accurately
so in the game karyakin de paulov which
I believe was a Blitz game in 2019 I
think karyakan probably achieved the
easiest win of his entire life after he
takes E5 which is of course the most
natural move for black as it as it does
eliminate the powerful Pawn on E5 and
also appears to not have any immediate
tactical consequences but this turns out
to be false as after Bishop G5
so black queen is forced to hold on to
the E7 Square so it moves like Queen D4
would result in Bishop E7 with a winning
attack for white as control of F6 f8 and
G5 at the same time is not going to be
feasible here
so instead after Queen D7
um Knight E4 the problem for black is
that the threat of Knight F6 is pretty
much decisive and would end the game
immediately and black doesn't have a
convincing way to protect the Rook on f8
from everything in the long run
so after F6 Bishop Z4
again the king is not able to go to h8
because f8 is hanging so Rook F7 was
played and then the uh
pawn and F6 simply drops and topalov
actually resigned in his position as
after Knight takes F6 Bishop takes F6 uh
black is not going to be able to prevent
a sword of checkmate
so let's move Bishop D3 definitely
creates a lot of serious problems for
black
um it turns out that of course this is
not a refutation of Black's idea or
anything black is able to survive with
best play
but we're going to be looking at uh and
in fact there's actually a couple of
ways for for black to do so
um so in the game uh Christopher you
against Ray Robson from the U.S
championship last year right here in St
Louis black did actually play a little
bit better than de paulov and managed to
survive the position so let's take a
look so first of all I should mention
that in this position black can play
Bishop E6 but I believe this is less
accurate than the way Robson played
essentially the idea of Bishop E6 is to
prepare the move F5 for black in order
to free up the position here
and indeed after Knight F6 Knight takes
F6 white can choose to take with either
the bishop or the pawn in both cases
with very strong compensation
but Robson decided to go for something
that is uh
I would say a little simpler than this
which is good for most Berlin players as
black should be in my opinion if black
is playing Berlin the goal is to
simplify the game
chess tactics says I know how to break
the Berlin play D4 instead mission
accomplished a lot of people are going
for that but I think I think if that was
the right way to go I think much fewer
top players would be playing E4
in fact it's actually sort of problem
with the uh game philosophy that I
personally have so
um
basically it's just like um so with the
with the move uh D4 on move one I feel
like black has several openings that can
kill the game and therefore
it's sort of like I'm avoiding the
Berlin by allowing a bunch of other
berliners instead so personally not
really my sort of thing but of course D4
is not bad just I don't think it really
solves the problem in the long run of
black playing very solidly
so Robinson ended up going for Queen E7
which is the best move so the idea here
is that now in the case of Bishop G5
black will simply be able to capture on
E5 with the queen and after Queen G7
there will be no attack and black will
have extra material
so after Queen E7 we have e takes D6
so Knight takes D6 Bishop G5 F6 Knight
D5 so this is all very concrete black is
not going to be able to permit white to
bring the bishop into F6 so after F6
Knight D5 Queen G7 Queen takes G7 King
takes G7 Knight takes C7 turns out that
the position is going to simplify up
very fast so it looks a little bit
strange how white is uh down in exchange
and has further a bishop attack but the
Rook on A8 is actually not salvageable
in this position so we can see that if
black wanted to attempt to Rook B8 in
order to try to solve this problem then
after Bishop F4
the sort of x-ray of the bishop to The
Rook here is very problematic for black
so if black were to try to save the
Knight with Knight F7 then after 98 we
have a discovered check and this end
game is winning for white with an extra
Pawn as well as the bishop pair so even
after finding Queen E7 black still has
to go through a couple of Hoops in order
to not immediately lose the game which
is very nice
um and the more obvious way for black to
defend Rook d8 is also not sufficient as
the position of the King on G7 is quite
unfortunate after Bishop takes D6 Rook
takes D6 and Knight E8
uh Anish Gary really likes the Berlin I
wonder why
um that's a great question uh I think
that Anish Gary likes the Berlin because
Everyone likes the Berlin at the top
level of Chess which is not a
coincidence so yes
um
so 97 98 Rook takes the eight Bishop
takes me it would be winning so black is
not going to be able to save that iflock
really wants to keep some sort of
imbalance in the position at this point
there is still Rook F7 after Bishop
takes F6 check which is pretty much
forced for white
then King takes F6 Knight takes A8 the
Knight on A8 appears to be trapped but
after B6 Rook D1 turns out it's very
difficult for black to actually make a
capture out of it so after Rook D7 for
example F3 and Bishop B7 is the natural
move to capture the Knight on A8
unfortunately after Bishop B5 white is
going to be able to save it with a
winning position at the end of the day
being up two pawns so very strange but
yeah indeed there's supposed to your
repetition here after a king of second
and Rook D1 so make of that which you
will
so in the game uh Christopher you
against Ray Robson F takes G5 was played
and they reached this sort of end game
very quickly which turns out to be a
draw I was hoping somehow that uh White
would have been able to win this game
but unfortunately uh Robson decided to
trade off the last two pawns and from
here the game is not really worth uh
instructional value
so why did I bring this up it appears
that there's a fast draw here where both
where the game ended up falling off
pretty fast so I would say that Bishop
D3 here is a little bit of an opening
trap I think it's great to use for one
game because the thing is that in the
best case scenario white has checkmated
in 20 moves so that's great right
and in the worst case scenario black has
made a draw and well that is black
school when Berlin happens anyway right
so really this move risks very little
and is a good try and I would say that
this is actually extremely valuable in
modern chess these days since uh it's
not always super obvious how
um how to like create a situation where
uh essentially what White's done is in
this situation
um
white has for very little risk created a
situation where black can go wrong and
that is very important in modern chess
as with best play everything is going to
be equal at the end of the day kramnik
drove kaspar of crazy with this yes that
is correct and that is indeed why
um that is indeed why the Berlin
continues to be so popular to this day
in the 2000 world championship match
between Kasparov and kramnik despite
being pretty much inarguably an inferior
player with a much lower rating and such
kramnik was able to hold draw pretty
much every game with black depending on
this opening which prior to that had
been considered to be dubious and
nowadays there is no other opening that
is more deeply analyzed
okay so for the last game today we're
going to be looking at something that is
a little bit more of a repertoire choice
and less of a sort of trap or a hope
chest or anything like this
and this is probably how I think that
white should play so or I shouldn't say
it should play but this is definitely I
think a good option for white to meet
the Berlin with every single game as you
can very quickly reach a position that
is pretty much inarguably slightly
preferable for white even if it's not
considered to be necessarily better for
white
so I know that sounds strange but we're
going to take a look at the game here we
have Ramesh Babu pragnananda playing
white and allerezo farooja playing Black
so this is a rapid game but the opening
Theory I think is very instructive so E4
E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 should be five
Knight of six so nothing terribly
unusual here
um castles Knight takes E4 and again
five rookie one which can be looking at
again here
Knight D6 Knight takes E5 Bishop E7
Bishop F1 we've seen this so far as the
same before but in this position instead
of playing D4 and Bishop D3 uh probably
Nanda decides to go for a
I wouldn't say more ambitious but more
open-ended plan let's say with Knight C3
so this move is far from unknown
um and so the primary idea is um well
who knows perhaps Julian can tell me
what is the primary idea for white with
the move Knight C3
actually oh great
yeah very good so the primary idea for
white is going to be with Knight D5 and
attempting to win the bishop pair here
so black generally meets this with 98 or
for 95 Bishop D6 just trying to hold on
to that Bishop for as long as possible
and in this position white is able to
continue with either the move rookie 2
or rookie one there's small differences
between both but rookie one is the
primary move that we're going to be
looking at right now
so after C6 Knight E3 and so the idea
here is that what is going to be playing
Knight F5 and Y is going to be either
capturing the bishop on D6 or with 97
Jack to capture the bishop on C8 and it
looks like it's a long a large loss of
time but in fact it is actually not so
easy for a black to prove the quality
against it
so in this position black wants to avoid
an immediate Knight F5 as that would
create a lot of pressure on the dark
Square Bishop so there is the so there's
the immediate uh Retreat for the of the
dark Square Bishop is the most common
way for black to play and there are two
possible Retreats so
we're going to be looking at an example
of Bishop C7 a little bit later the idea
after Bishop C7 is that white is going
to be playing Knight F5 and d597 to
capture the bishop on C8 so after King
h8
uh Knight takes hit Rook takes C8 D3 F5
so this position has been known for a
really long time and generally speaking
after G3 the position is considered to
be slightly preferable for white uh I
mean at the end of the day there is a
bishop pair but the position is pretty
holdable for black so the idea that
we're going to be focusing on today is
the move of Bishop F4 with the intention
of
of after Bishop takes F4 Queen takes F4
it looks very strange to give the bishop
hair after we tried so hard to achieve
it but the idea is that white is
eventually going to be playing G3 Bishop
G2 and C4 and in this way opening up the
position and this is an interesting plan
that we're going to be looking at in the
game here not through the exact move
order in this position for Russia decide
to play Bishop E7 instead but we're
going to be achieving a very similar
idea here
should be 7 Knight of five Bishop G5
D3 so this position had traditionally
been considered to be like pretty safe
for black since black is eliminating the
bishop Pair by trading the dark screw
Bishops but indeed the situation after
C4 is extremely uncomfortable for black
mostly due to the fact that uh the white
light Square Bishop is going to be more
useful in every single end game than the
Black Knight
so we have Knight F6
Queen B3 just creating a little bit more
pressure on B7
so this position
um
perusa decided that it was the most
important to play Queen F4 and return
the queen back to the queen side here
with Queen C7
so G3 was played um so a problem with
Queen takes B7 is that black is
threatening Knight G4 which would create
a double attack on the F2 and H2 pawns
so we have G3 Queen C7
and now after Queen A3 Buck is in sort
of a tough situation because the A7 Pawn
is hanging and it moves like A6 to
protect it would allow Rook E7 with a
rook entering the seventh rank here
which would be very uncomfortable for
black
so we have the move uh C5 played in the
game
but after C takes D5 Knight takes D5 we
can see that the position has opened up
and eventually a white Bishop on G2 is
going to be very strong and dominating
the board
so Rook C1 very natural move in this
position white is actually uh
threatening to move d4 to take advantage
of the pin and capture that pawn on C5
so of course Perugia sees this and
avoids it with Queen V6 but now after
Rook E5 it turns out that the position
is very much not stable for black and
indeed after Knight B4 the move d4
became as a very strong surprise for
farrugia so the C5 Pawn is actually not
going to be salvageable here so after C
takes D4 Rook takes C8 and then Rook B5
will result in a winning position for
white as this Fork will ensure the win
of a piece
so very tough situation for black and
indeed after Knight C6 Rook takes C5
white was able to pick up the C5 Pawn
for very little compensation and after
D5
um
ended up winning fairly smoothly here
so Bishop G2 preparing Rook C7 by
holding D5 a little bit further
um and indeed after Rook C7 Rook B8 now
uh probably Nanda does something pretty
smart here with Queen A3 so after Queen
B6 or so if black were to trade Queens
this end game would be losing for black
as the d-pawn is not going to be
stoppable here in the long run and the
white Rooks are significantly more
active than the black ones so after
Queen B6 D4 so perusa is trying to keep
Queens on to maintain as much counter
play as possible Queen D4 threatening
Knight D3 credit to farooza for playing
as tenaciously as possible
but after a queen C5 prognanda sees that
there's an opportunity here to trade
Queens as black wishes to keep them with
Queen takes B2 then F4 is going to be
abusing a skewer here along the fifth
rank to pick at the H5 Pawn after which
it is actually Black's King that is
under the more serious threats
so Rook of Fate played
um so the idea for blacks after Queen
takes G6 Queen D4 check would be able to
recuperate the bishop on D5 and black
would actually be pretty much fine there
of course prognanda is not the sort of
player who's going to allow that to
happen so King H1
and if we just take a look at the pieces
here black is completely dominated here
that light Square Bishop is completely
controlling every part of the board
and the D6 Pawn is not going to be easy
to stop as well as the Rook on C7
applying pressure through both sides
again
so we have Queen F6 D7 Queen D6 and then
Bishop E4
so yeah basically there's a problem here
for black and after Queen F5
white has a lot of plans here in which
to win slowly but H4 H5 is very simple
with the idea of delivering the queen to
H7 with mate
so in the game black tries to forestall
this for as long as possible by taking
the A2 Pawn but in the long run there's
no way to stop it as that D7 Pawn cannot
be moved away
so yeah very impressive demonstration
from prognanda and a good illustration
of how strong this plan is with uh C4 it
can be so it shows us how dangerous this
this sort of situation is
um so now that I think about it I
believe that I actually forgot to
um include one of my
games here so let me see if I can find
it
um
nice okay there we go sorry
all right so yeah so the uh the last
game we're going to be looking at today
is between uh again my friend Edward
song and with black the Grand Master uh
Milan Packer so let's play Budapest in
2018 and after Bishop D6 my friend went
for rookie two so I believe that rookie
2 is a theoretically slightly worse move
but we're going to be looking at this
game primarily for the ideas rather than
for the actual opening moves so I
believe this is acceptable to use for
this lecture today
so after Rook E2 C6 uh it looks a little
bit weird to place the Rook on E2 here
rather than E1 but the idea is that
eventually white is going to transfer
the A1 Rook to E1 and therefore having
to work preemptively on E2 is going to
enable an easier doubling of Rooks so
after Bishop C7 Knight F5 again the
ideas here are very similar G3 Knight D6
D3 and F5 so in this position white is
not really aiming to exchange the dark
score Bishops as Bishop F4 is always
slightly annoying since black is able to
take an F4 then white would have to
double the pawns and this is why I
suggest rookie one actually since in the
case of Queen F3
the exchange of Bishops will not have
this problem and white can continue with
that C4 plan that we saw on the previous
game
but even without this C4 plan we're
about to see that the situation can
still be very dangerous for black and
surprisingly so given the symmetry of
the position
so after Bishop D2 Queen F6 and Bishop
C3 in this position black had already
committed a serious error with the move
d4
so it looks very natural to shut out the
bishop and create a and gain some space
at the same time but after Bishop D2 C5
we can see that very quickly black has
resulted in a black has created a very
bad situation as the light Square Bishop
is going to be dominant on the long
diagonal so just another example of how
easy it is for Black to mess up in this
even in this fairly symmetrical Pawn
structure and definitely preferable over
the Berlin end game in my opinion uh is
that chess base uh yes it is okay so
Bishop G2
uh B5 but now after A4 the problem for
black is that if black wishes to play
for A6 and after a takes B5 a takes B5 B
Queen Side Pawn structure has been kept
intact but black is not going to be able
to challenge the a file at any point due
to White's powerful Bishop on G2 which
uh for black pretty much cuts the board
in half and white can proceed with
either Rook A6 or Rook A7 and this
difference in activity is going to be
extremely unpleasant for black to deal
with
so in the game uh Milan Packer decided
to play B4 and keep the position as
closed as possible
but the problem for black is that the
dark Square Bishop on C7 is very unhappy
with how black has decided to set up on
the queen side
and after Queen F1 A5 Rook ae1 black is
now forced to exchange Rooks along the
e-file which will result in a pretty
rough situation for black now
so um after rookie 8
Rook takes the eight Rook takes E8 takes
takes
uh the position at first might look like
it is a draw and indeed if a few more
pieces came off that might be the case
but the problem for black is that uh
that white is going to make sure that
that does not happen and after if we E2
Queen E5 yeah white definitely doesn't
want to be trading Queens here so we
have Queen F3 and black is not going to
be able to prevent the White Queen from
invading the position on one of C6 B7 or
A8
so after G6 Queen C6 Knight G7 yeah this
position is pretty lost over black a
little bit surprisingly but the White
Queen is super powerful and that Bishop
on C7 contributes basically nothing to
the game
so in this position white would love to
play Bishop F4 creating a skewer along
the diagonal here
um
but Bishop F4 in this case allows Queen
E1 check so white plays an excellent
move here to avoid that with King F1
and after Queen D6 Queen B7
we see 96 Bishop H6 and black is pretty
much completely paralyzed here uh very
soon White's going to be invading on C8
with White Queen
and after 98 Queen C8 black is actually
in a situation where very soon he's
going to run out of moves so
should be six B3
and in this position black finally
decided that he has run out of moves and
played King G8 which is a little bit sad
um but after King G8 Bishop F4 now white
is able to execute active plans as only
black is stuck and white is not so after
if we use six Queen B8
um
black decide to continue uh bringing the
key into the game with King F7 but after
Bishop D6 that Bishop on B6 is trapped
and therefore lost and indeed the game
finished in this position
I'm so happy to see somebody losing it
bro then well that's the purpose of the
lecture isn't it
um
wow okay I did not plan this very well
because I've run out
so you have an idea against 1965 but the
reason why I stopped playing the system
was actually
instead of 95.
instead of uh sorry so where would that
be
here yeah okay
um that's a great question
um
I don't remember offhand actually I
think this is this is interesting
because I don't think people really play
this way anymore with black do they
um yeah I mean it's like the computer
says it's slightly worse than the other
way but
like practically I the reason why I
played this one was to get like the
bishop pair right right
but you don't get that like white was
like night a year or whatever
Peter gives some Advantage but I don't
know
so you're talking about like something
like this
yeah so there are a couple of of issues
here for for black surprisingly despite
the uh symmetrical Pawn structure I mean
okay obviously this isn't like the the
ideal position that we're like really
happy to have with white all the time
but uh the position should definitely be
like slightly easier for white to play
in the uh in for a couple of reasons so
first of all the Knight on C6 is very
poorly placed
um it I mean it just doesn't really have
anywhere to go from C6 right
um so the Knight on C6 is very poorly
placed and so black is going to have to
spend a couple of Tempe to re-home it
most likely through uh some sort of
Bishop F6 and Knight C7 but that leaves
black with a pretty bad Bishop on f62
since C3 is going to be very effective
at shutting it out
um I mean I'm sure white should play C3
in this position I don't think uh I
don't think that's too difficult of a
decision there and the none and F5 can
go to D6 from which it is pretty good
but the other night is going to have a
very difficult time finding a a good
square if your knight is present on D6
and so yeah I guess this is probably why
people don't really play this so much
now is my is my assumption
um
yeah I mean it is it is a good point
about like how people work with
computers though because like the
computer will choose this position over
the one we just talked about like every
single time but I think for a human play
I think that this is like way easier for
white than for black is my opinion
um Shadow Sprite 54 says isn't D3 the
best way to play against the Berlin Yeah
we actually talked about that a little
bit earlier in the lecture in fact we
can probably go back and discuss some
more theoretical aspects of it since uh
since uh since we have so much time
remaining
um so let me just go back there really
quick
sorry that is not in fact the correct
database
so yeah we can just talk a little bit
about this here so
yeah so here we were just talking about
how after it should be five
um 92 Castle is Knight C4 96. so first
of all black does not have to Castle
immediately and it's also possible to
play uh for F6 first but in this
particular case I think that uh in this
case the short castling plan is a little
bit more effective as after Castle's
black is already committed to F6 and I
think that the plan for white involves
C3 and B4 typically
um I mean at the end of the day nothing
that black needs to be like super
worried about but I believe that this
position does end up being slightly
preferable for white
um so I guess we can talk now about how
after castles Knight c497
um we can do a little bit of a more
theoretical exploration into 93.
so yeah after Knight E3
um
yeah so as we were talking about in this
game with Edward and gory black played
rookie which is perfectly fine
um after G4 I believe here uh black
normally plays a pretty fast A5
generally speaking and tries to run the
pawn to A4 and there are various
theoretical details
um it seems like a better version of the
Reversed hand hem
what does the Reversed hand have
okay I have no idea what that is so
perhaps you'll have to enlighten me from
from the chat there thank you
um
yeah but basically I think this is a
really good uh try for white
um
yeah geez
and fill the door oh okay sure so
yeah I guess I guess you actually could
get something like this from a reversed
fillador
um if you like play 92 and Knight C4
very early I never really made that
connection so thank you but
um I guess in that case there is
um
what's it called Uh there's a white
light strip Bishop that is pretty weak
in that line so maybe this is a maybe
this is a better version
uh you don't have to go fish take C6 you
can also go for C3 or castles yeah yeah
both of those are are totally fine
um I don't think anything's wrong with
that but I do think that this line with
uh 893 is actually a really good try for
black uh sorry good try for white to
reach an attacking position
um as pretty much no matter what black
does you're going to be able to play G4
which is I mean I don't know about you
guys but for me I always want to play G4
whenever possible
um
so yeah I think this is a really good uh
try to reach an attacking position for
white
um
yeah okay so
wow I can't believe I misjudged my
timing so badly it's never never
happened before
um so I guess if nobody has any further
questions that's probably it
um
okay
um all right well then thank you
everybody sorry about the uh
sort of uh false advertising but yeah
okay my bad I'll I'll see you guys next
time thank you
[Music]